and i got to tell you the number one
question that i get from people online
is where is raven's mom
what are you doing i'm scared
that's cute but what if someone actually
heard you so are you in touch with
takiyah and and what is that
conversation like are we bringing her
back takiyah and i still have a lovely
relationship we talk um we don't talk
all the time but we talk enough to know
that we're still in each other's lives
there's a call out to her as well and
tanya baxter is still in england she is
getting her full life as a lawyer and
she sends money home so thanks mom
how do you think we have this big house
in san francisco of a restaurant i don't
think so i'm a baxter cutting the check
you know what amy thanks for sending
money home so no don't worry about that
thank you everybody for um loving tonya
as well we love her so much and takia
crystal kamah is such an amazing
comedian i learned so much from her when
we did this show in the beginning so we
definitely have to
keep our fingers crossed i'm sure at
some point you know um everybody will
come back that's just the way it goes
and i hear there's rumors of takiyah
even coming back yes tanya that'd be
cool are we gonna get some answers are
we gonna see her are we gonna find out
what she's doing where she is there's a
upcoming episode that it's mentioned and
talked about okay um but that's all i
can say so vic is still married
vic is still married okay good to know
what's she up to what can you tease
there'll be some mention about it okay
and it'll leave you just as confused
i mean i feel like we hear about all the
other characters and she's the one that
it's kind of like the question mark
that's still remaining people ask people
ask and i go i don't know what to tell
you okay are you are you friendly with
takiyah in real life um uh yes but i
haven't talked to her in a long time
okay yeah so it's not like you're
texting her like we gotta get you back
here we gotta get some answers we'd love
her to have her back yeah yeah okay if
if you could if you could tease in maybe
an adjective or two how that storyline
might tie up what would you say once
upon a time
there was a king
and a queen
this will make sense when you see the
episode
yeah a king hopefully a king and a queen
reunited
king and a queen they live in kingdoms
thanks babe couldn't have done it
without you you're always there for me
gotcha
what's up with that
so season five are you watching raven's
home of course of course i'm watching
wavings home yeah i gotta make sure
rondell is holding down the fort and
that he's funny not funnier than me but
funny no never never know you're all
funny in your own unique ways and of
course the fans miss you and they miss
your on-screen son and test are you in
touch with the old cast are you are you
trying to wrangle them over here and put
them in this episode you're so sweet i
know i know i'm sure at some point you
know um everybody will come back that's
just the way it goes jason and i see
each other all the time i mean he is
like an extension of me now and i do
feel like a second mother and we have
dinners and stuff skye's in new york so
it's a little harder and she's busy
being a music queen and you know an
instagram star so but um we'll be back
together again disney doesn't let you go
what does that mean to you to be
reunited with your former cast member oh
my god lisa is the best in the whole
wide world we love annalisa so much and
having her back with us is such a joy
and she's she's always brought such life
to our set we break for lunch at 12 but
11 30 11 45 she'll go that's lunch one
hour that's lunch one hour
we got that iconic moment back this week
so it's so great to have her back you
found a beautiful way to bring the
character of chelsea back our calls out
to nia our calls out to tess our calls
out to levi are we gonna see these faces
come back we have calls out to everyone
that has ever been a part of the raven
baxter family even from the original
show to now so there are lots of calls
out some people have voice mails some
people still have two ways so as long as
we can you know speak qwerty i'm sure
we're good i don't know 13 9. i love
that
have you guys connected with with those
actors would you want to see them come
back for an episode or two i think work
being able to work with those characters
who came before would be absolutely
amazing i personally have not met
any of them but i would love to because
i think that i respect them
wholeheartedly and i think they're
awesome and to work with them would just
be
the ultimate crossover and yes a joy yes
okay what do you think nia comes back
maybe tess comes back
i'm there man like let's do it that'd be
that'd be fun yeah maybe if one of them
had a little thing with neil i think
that would cause some shenanigans with
uh with booker he probably wouldn't like
his sister and neil
did you imagine nia and neil god it
rolls right off the tongue it sounds so
perfect right no i no it would be great
for them to come i've met a few of them
in real life yeah they're very very
sweet people so it'd be great to finally
get to work with them are you in touch
with any of those actors would you love
to see them come back to the show
i mean i would love to have them on like
an epis a couple of episodes that would
be so much fun of course auntie ray is
always video chatting with nia
seeing that she's like staying with her
dad and you know following on the rules
and whatnot so yeah but that would be so
much fun to have them on the show and
i'm a huge fan so
yeah we've seen our fair share of booker
getting into trouble but i'm really
liking seeing booker the ladies man all
clear
looking good
what can you tell me about the love
story there that might unfold well
around 16 17 we all get into our little
relationships without trying to figure
things out i feel like she's a really
good match for his energy because she's
she's kind of chill and toned back and
you know booker's always on 10. so it's
nice for him to have someone who's you
know kind of chilling laid back but yeah
growing up he's he's changing he's
maturing so it's it's nice getting to
play him of course and and with growing
up and with more love in his life i mean
can you tease is there gonna be a kiss
at some point in season five we actually
filmed two kisses i don't know which one
they're gonna use um whichever one comes
out when y'all see it let me know
as an actor is that your first on-screen
kiss it was how did that feel i was you
know it's crazy marissa reyes who plays
cami she kept telling me i was being
weird i think i was like go no because i
was so chill throughout the week i was
like
and then like when it was the last scene
of the day like we had gone all day no
one talked about it really not to me i
don't want to say anything i thought
guys he got it i just got me cool when
we got there i was like
okay you good you you need um you need i
need a a mint let's get a it was it was
literally like four or five seconds it
was
prepared yeah
[Music]
you